hey grammarians today i want to talk
about the idea of the indefinite pronoun
which looks kind of complicated but
really just does what it says on the tin
an indefinite pronoun is just that it's
indefinite undefined uncertain
these are pronouns that we use when
we're not being especially specific
words like any
anybody
each everyone nobody
anytime i need to remember what words
fall into this category of indefinite
pronouns i just think of the song
everybody needs somebody to love
originally by solomon burke and then
later made famous by the rolling stones
and the blues brothers so a cool thing
about indefinite pronouns actually there
are a couple number one
they can be used as both subjects or
objects in a sentence
so if you said to me david do you want
pizza
i could respond yes please i'd love some
using it as an object
or equally plausibly i could say yes
please some would be great
using it as a subject
another really cool thing about
indefinite pronouns is that the words
both neither and either retain the dual
they are some of the only words in
english that refer to
only two things
so these three pronouns are actually a
little bit less indefinite than most
indefinite pronouns because they refer
to a set of two things
so if someone asked me you know do you
like mangoes or cherries more i could
say i like both equally referring to the
cherries and the mangoes at the same
time and this is really strange because
in english
this dual case doesn't really exist
anymore except for in very limited
amounts because english distinguishes
between whether or not there's one of
something and more than one of something
but this is one of the very few cases
where we ever distinguish between more
than one of something and specifically
two of something there are not a whole
lot of words in english that refer to
that uh so i think that's really cool
the third cool thing about indefinite
pronouns is that they're usually treated
as singular
usually
so words like both neither and either
are obviously plural but there are some
that are a little bit fuzzier
for example in the sentence nobody was
home we used the word was the singular
form
even though that nobody could refer to
multiple people or it's really referring
to the absence of anyone
similarly in the sentence everybody
knows that i love onions we use the word
nose just like we'd say he knows she
knows it knows so that's the the
singular form of that verb
even though the idea of everybody would
seem to refer to more than one person
the the indefinite pronoun that we use
to refer to everybody usually conjugate
the third person singular form of verbs
usually
let's uh get to one of the weirder
examples though because sometimes the
context can carry you along into
something that might seem a little quote
unquote ungrammatical but really
reflects the way that language is used
today
and so although you might say everyone
you know is looking at me
here's an example from garner's modern
american usage which is one of the
several car-sized books i'm using to
construct this grammar course
everyone was crouched behind furniture
to surprise me but i already knew they
were there
and you can see in the beginning of the
sentence we say everyone was
but then in the second part of the
sentence we say they
were and we're using they to refer to
everyone
so how can this be this doesn't seem
grammatical
but as garner says
sometimes meaning rather than grammar
governs agreement
is this grammatical yes in that it makes
sense
does it adhere concretely and in an
ironclad way to these rules that we've
established no but language is kind of
messy in that way
sometimes the meaning of the sentence
the the fact that here everyone refers
to multiple people is going to override
the rules that are previously
established
and that's okay uh as long as you're
making sense
so relative pronouns are usually
singular unless the context drags them
into the realm of the plural so like
their name implies sometimes indefinite
pronouns can be a little
indefinite all right here are the three
cool things about indefinite pronouns
number one they can be used as subjects
or objects
both neither and either retain the dual
form which is super weird and number
three
indefinite pronouns are usually treated
as singular
usually i know that's confusing but i
have faith in you you can learn anything
dave it out